so I know nothing about any of you here
I'm going to introduce numb focus the
nonprofits that is behind the PI data
group behind the group do you have here
now and behind the overruns or PI H as
we have around the world and talk a
little bit about community and why we
need this kind of group but to do that I
need to know tiny bit about to you first
of all so how many of you here go to the
regular Python meetups it might be lots
of it might be few of you only a couple
of you okay but all of you who have the
hands down can some of you shout out how
you knew about this event which one brag
point a meter okay and it's that one
that everyone else recognizes no we
would terribly quiet yeah some nods okay
I'm gonna ask you some more questions
like your honor so drink some more beer
so I'm always curious as to why people
come together and why they come and join
communities and where they come from and
also what their motivation is is it just
to learn something new and then
disappear elsewhere or is it because
you've got some deeper Drive in a
community or an ethos or a software
stack or whatever which will keep you
coming around so a tiny bit about me so
I'm an engineering data scientist I say
that because there are many data
scientists who came out of university
with a PhD so they have some kind of
full training in that I don't have that
formal training I've made all of this up
as I've gone along but I've been doing
it for 15 years back before we add the
term data scientist so I've been doing
this back when you could be an
artificial intelligence researcher in
industry applying academic work to
industrial solutions a title that nobody
including myself understood what was the
best that I came up with and then later
we got the term data scientist and
suddenly I had a shared vocabulary with
people who might employ me which was
quite nice how many people here are PhDs
in their respective areas around data
science
I've been asking any questions to put
your hands up so a couple of you pH DS
okay alright so not so many PhDs so you
don't have a PhD of course to do theydo
science you can just make it all up that
you go along and I work back in London
so I work with teams coaching them so I
tend to work with teams of junior and
intermediate Baker scientists where
perhaps they're being given lots of
requirements by management team where
the management team aren't necessarily
very numerous they don't know how to ask
the right questions of a data science
team and the juniors which can be like
graduates from a ph.d program but
Giulia's in an industrial environment
are saying yes we can do all of that and
then it turns out you can't do all of
that and you have to push back and so I
go and help a team there I provide
training and then I solve problems with
with companies and I really love doing
this I really really enjoy really enjoy
how ignorant I am and how off the 15
years I only realize just how much more
ignorant I am than when I started
and I'm massively driven by the idea of
trying to fill in all those holes and of
course our domain expands those holes
get bigger and bigger it's kind of
terrifying but it's kind of brilliant
too
so as I mentioned I'm one of the
cofounders of planets in London I wrote
the book on high performance of Python
and with O'Reilly some years ago and
when I work with a whole bunch of
different companies so why do we care
about community building so this this
first talk 20 minutes is about community
and um focus as we get the things and
Andre slides kind of stole some of this
thunder in fact and rate them with your
slides still a bunch of it I was going
to talk about so we have shared values
we want to promote maybe we want to
collaborate with other people who have
shared ideas on techniques or domains of
interest maybe we want to find new
friends so I took later about why I
started the meetup in London and it was
because I couldn't find anyone to share
a beer with me and talk about data
science way back when and it turns out
now I've got lots of people who like
talking about this stuff but probably
the thing that unifies a lot people many
of you here is this idea of
having access to high quality software
so techniques and software that solve
our problems behind all of this if we
build a community there are interesting
things we want to do typically they
require some money and some organization
and then that leads us to the problem of
lots of boring problems that need
solving so who knows of the PSF the
Python Software Foundation is the show
of hands only a handful of you for the
Python Software Foundation is the
non-profit entity in the United States
that amongst other things defends the
Python trademark around the language and
it provides lots of governance around
the source code so that other companies
can't steal it manipulate it call it
their own and turn it to their own evil
corporate ends and so it provides that a
level playing field for the rest of us
to use the Python language and numb
focus is the equivalent that we have for
the data science world several years ago
there was some kind of trademark and
concern a company in Europe was trying
to take on that trademark as their own
in his ours they said and the PSF
defends the trademark and so that's one
of the boring things that none of you
want to worry ourselves with be awfully
upset if you were a Python program or
one day and the next day you had to pay
a license fee for some other company to
say I'm a Python programmer and so those
kind of things don't happen because we
have these organizations that defend
some of these requirements right in
conference contracts incredibly boring
you need a legal entity to deal with
that marketing so the PI data brand
markets our PI data organizations around
the world and promotes them so they're
more visible so that we haven't got to
invest all of our time doing that
marketing and things like managing
grants and I'll talk about those in a
moment as well
so I probably have told you to smile and
say it's a non focus backs a lot of the
things in our PI data world is a legal
entity it's a 501 C I think is the right
name a US nonprofit and it's amongst
other things provides the me tongue
comma hosting which runs to tens of
thousands of dollars a year now for all
of the pie dates and meetups around the
world so the local organizers don't have
to pay for that out of their own pocket
which is a good thing it provides a code
of conduct and we saw an example of that
on the screen earlier and that means
that whenever I go to a PI data event
around the world I can assume that we've
all got similar shared values and that
if anybody steps out of line and it's
not particularly cool for somebody else
regarding their race related and sex
gender whatever it is that's covered by
the code of conduct that this person is
infringing upon we can do something
about it and it will start with a
conversation for saying hey that's not
cool we should you should modify that
maybe you need to go and say sorry and
it can be escalated if needs be the
Python Software Foundation has had to do
similar things with the hike on us
conference with several thousand at
Indies every year and some hijinks lots
of drinking every now and again things
head up at hand and they have to step in
and do something to make sure the
community maintains its core shared
values and it can be seen to correct
inappropriate behavior when things step
out of line so that it is inclusive for
everyone so encourage my stuff first
community numb focus also organizes
sprints so we can do hackathons things
like panda sprints so we can add lots of
new code and some easy shared
environments where we haven't got to go
and organize all of it ourselves
and you get stickers as well and so I
brought a gift via America five packs of
stickers I've got pie mc3 num focus I've
got pandas and could you please open up
that bag of stickers and then of course
what you want to do is adorn your laptop
back with lots of stickers because then
we're doing the marketing in the
promotion you don't have to do but
clearly I do and I think Lawson took as
well so look at this screen this is all
of the projects so almost all of the
projects that are currently primarily
supported through non focus and
put up your hand if you use at least one
of these on a daily basis I'm going to
ask you any questions so just freely put
your hands up so hands up hands up and
up
alright so it's pretty much always we
use at least one of these hands up if
you use say three of these on a weekly
monthly basis okay and then maybe five
of those when I can't even name all of
those okay so so a lot of you use at
least some of the tools that are
financially backed by numb focus and so
the reason you can earn a salary you
have your academics type end and you
enjoy using Python and these tools in
your spare time is in part because of
the financial backing an organization
provided by a non focus that's not the
only reason of course is because there
were lots of volunteers who promote
support and develop this code marketing
document it test it but part of that
happens because we get the financial
support bringing people together for
these springs so what kind of results to
be get out of the number focus back in
so we get lots of funding arranged by
companies supporting them focus or by
conferences so the PI data London
conference that I hope to run in in
London and we raid I forget the exact
number somewhere around a hundred two
thousand dollars for last year's
conference that went to number focus and
there are some costs that come out of
that other bits but as a gross lump of
money about a hundred thousand dollars
went towards num focus from the
volunteer effort from those of us in
London which is a Pacific anchor money
that can go towards grants so that non
focus thing can then disperse grants to
people who want to run sprints so
there's panda sprints
there's the John Hunter and maps map got
lib some fellowship put your hands up if
you use mcLaughlin
and that's probably all of us I'm
guessing certainly it's the main plot
enthrall in Python for a lot of years it
didn't have as much love as it needed
and what it had
one one character behind it John hunter
he was the main driver of all of the
work behind Matt katli we did an
incredible amount of work and I'm
unfortunately several years ago he died
of cancer he died very quickly and it
was a huge loss to our ecosystem he put
a lot of work in and devoted a lot of
time for all about benefit and so to
recognize that number focus put up this
grant and so every summer they run a
fellowship program for several people to
be paid to work on that public and
promote it so that serves two purposes
one is to provide new software to all of
us without any of us doing anything
that's brilliant
and also it enhances the career of the
people who are going into these
fellowship programs so they get a leg up
and they become more visible they've got
something on their season to show hey I
understand how open-source works and
demonstrably I'd improve the ecosystem
so the google Summer of Code project
says supported via some of this num
focus work
has anyone been a google Summer of Code
member said anyone mentor somebody in
the peaceful program I am no I mean it
started out the US and is drifting
across the world and so under this
program I think Google facilitates it
such that's independent mentors can then
mentor some kind of junior someone
younger who's coming into the ecosystem
and there's some financial aid put
around that to bring the people together
so that the people in the program can
contribute to open source and enhance
their CV and give us free new tools
we've got a 116 meetups I don't know
where I guess you're the hundred and
sixteen for 115 for something given this
is the first one but congratulations
you're part of this huge great growing
ecosystem and I'm really hoping that
this is going to grow back and you're
going to get more involved we've had
tens of conferences of every or this
year and every year we've gone up from a
handful of conferences five years ago
now we have tens per year and one of the
outputs of that is all the videos go
into YouTube and they're free so all
that knowledge that's been compiled and
then put together and then distribute it
out there it's freely available from
many cons
is in different languages around the
world and that's just one of those nice
little educational resources that's
hundreds going on thousands of hours of
free educational material compiled for
your benefit where you have to do
nothing for it that's right that really
enhances your career and it comes to
free and via the continued work to
improve the diversity in the ecosystem
we have we had we just have a really
friendly community I remember reading
years and years ago about a description
there was a British computer publication
the register talked about how different
programming groups different languages
kind of characterized themselves and it
talked about the price the world being
full of happy pockets they were just
smiling happy people who helped each
other and drank up the area generally
quite jolly and I liked that and it was
like 10 years ago I read about that and
I think it's still kind of true we're
just a friendly bunch who support other
people are more kind of nice to each
other so there's some of the conferences
that are coming up in the coming months
you got water sort not far from you next
year all of the major pipe Acer meetups
around the world are beginning their
planning for their next round the
conference isn't at the great deceiver
some of those may be speaking of some of
them so this is our current community
London so the the meter that I
co-founded with five years old now we
were the first PI data outside of the
USA so it started with a conference and
I was getting phone calls from Travis
Oliphant some of you would recognize
that name is the guy who made numpy and
numpy is the numeric library behind all
of the tools that were using was getting
phone calls from travis saying yeah we
want to run a pied-a-terre in london
we'd love you to host it
suppose brilliant but I'm writing this
book for O'Reilly I'm working and I'm
trying to find a house kind of got a lot
on my plate at the moment I don't want
to go and volunteer to run a conference
this went on for a little while and then
one day I got a phone call from Travis
saying yeah we booked the conference it
starts in five weeks time we've started
selling tickets we haven't got any
speakers could you do something about it
right well okay either I run the other
word
all except this interesting opportunity
where the conference is financially
backed it's got a venue tickets are on
sale I know lots of people we could
probably bring a conference together and
most of the hard works been taken care
of
so for 24 hours I'm out everyone that I
knew saying put in a conference proposal
and we've got a whole pile through we
had a good selection committee and every
round the first conference the first
conference was 200 people and it was
organized in five weeks with Cecelia
Liao and Emlyn clay my two co-founders
now what the monthly meter has over 200
people that's every month in a hedge
fund and the conference has grown to 500
people so we grow we've scaled a heck of
a lot learned a lot along that time
ninety-five thousand members around the
world this is an incredible achievement
many people in this ecosystem are
contributing their knowledge by talking
about something I want to encourage all
of you to think about doing and you can
stand on stage and wave your arms and
drink beer and it's all very nice and
you get to give back to this community
that provides all the tools and and
that's I guess there's a good connecting
point there how many of you make your
salary out of Pi data so it could be
academic salary industrial salary or
whatever how many of you are paid in
some shape or form because of the pie
dates ecosystems or the Python data
science ecosystem let's put your hands
up if you're you earned money because of
this ecosystem it's got to be more than
a couple of you know I certainly do most
of you use pandas on a weekly basis you
said all right you know in that
ecosystem so that means that most of you
are owning your salary by consuming from
this ecosystem so a very sensible thing
to do is to contribute back to the sea
ecosystems and balance things up so I
mentioned earlier that one of my reasons
for starting the meetup was to meet
like-minded folk I live down in Brighton
sunny beautiful little parts of the UK
and where everyone's a designer
everyone's got cool ideas about design
nobody cares about data at least that's
the case back then I couldn't find
anyone to talk to about data science and
AI as it
but we started this group squaring to
8,000 members brilliant after every
meetin up we go to the pub when we have
very conversations around data science
I'm just so happy and I get a big rid of
my face I don't know I'm a geek and I'm
really really happy and very comfortable
with that for my personal career I get
invited to speak around the world which
is brilliant I get to go to places like
Prague I've never been to which is
lovely to come and to come to somewhere
new meet new people recently I received
a community leadership awards for five
years of grammar and talking and doing
this which is very lovely it's lovely as
well because it means that none focus is
recognizing the people who are putting
their time into other parts of the
ecosystem not just writing the tools or
running the events but also going out
and promoting these events so if you're
interested in in that angle have a look
at numbers and see there's a plethora of
different awards they gave and it
involves a trip to New York when you
receive an award so it's a nice way to
go and meet another part of the
ecosystem you wouldn't normally meet I
get better consulting options which is
great time I run my own consultancy so I
want to meet interesting people and I
get interesting collaborations I've been
on and off working with an NHS
researchers at the National Health
System in the UK and he's been working
on the ventilator date there babe sorry
ventilator and data for prematurely born
babies and I've been working with him
using the data science ecosystem with
his Python acknowledge to get better at
understanding the dynamics of this
baby's breathing and which means with
save or helping to improve healthcare
around babies I do that unpaid because
it makes the world a better place and it
makes me happen these different
opportunities all available to you if
you get more involved in more prominence
in this ecosystem so I'm going to finish
here there are a couple of tips to
running a successfully meet up an
ecosystem around it we're gonna have a
chat tomorrow have a little workshop
around how to do this to promote growth
here in your ecosystem some of the most
obvious points are lung the eventual
regularly and have high quality speakers
so many of you if not all of you in here
have something you could share
you might not want to share it you're a
little bit slow to put your hands up at
the moment but you will have good
knowledge right so if you're using
Python and the PI data ecosystem on a
weekly or monthly basis you've all
learned things that nobody else knows in
the room you could all share that back
that's one of the ways to contribute
back to the community so many of you
here could be speed because you could do
a five-minute talk you were 20 minutes
or 30 minutes walk and this opportunity
is available to you make your speakers
and make your organizers famous so
anyone who's volunteering in this
ecosystem they should get something out
of it so when one of you stands up you
spend hours or days writing a talk and
you get up in an evening and give the
talk everyone around you should try and
do a little bit to make you a bit more
famous that's my humble opinion pretty
strong in that opinion and I think
anyone volunteering their time to
strengthen the ecosystem should get
something back and at least recognition
Thanks networking so we drink beer we
talk to each other and you never know
who you might meet and where that might
lead you can join non focus either was a
financially supporting member or just
join the mailing list and read about
what's going on and my top tip here for
you is just be creative don't worry
about what's a numb focus might mean in
your mind and what PI data might mean
and what the rules and regulations might
be do the right thing for your local
community and grow it up filling of the
wider ecosystem of course but do the
right thing grow it up make it vibrant
make it work here and then you'll have a
lovely sustaining a little meetup and
that'll be a really nice thing to see
occurring on a regular basis so I'm
going to finish talking for the first
focus there thank you very much
[Applause]
should I take questions
Oh are there any questions I'll be
around for beer afterwards I'm happy to
talk them as well
any questions if not I'll move on to the
second talk no questions okay alright so
the second talk is very different in
nature
so so first of all I like alliterations
so we're going to talk about deftly
delivering data science projects I
couldn't come up with Addie for projects
I just yeah I ran out of steam there but
I tried to get all the same letter in
the title so one of the things that I do
I mentioned I work with companies back
in London on coaching and teaching and
one thing I work quite hard on is the
strategic side of how do we make teams
work how do we make the wider team work
so that the data science in a company in
the whole from management all the way
down what does a plan look like and then
how do the data scientists actually
deliver projects successfully so how do
we get them to ask the right questions
do the right thing and then deliver a
thing that's actually valuable rather
than other singers that kind of curve
and I am doing that increasingly
Einsteins talk much more about it so
this is the first delivery of this talk
so not only would I like your feedback
later I would like criticism please what
did I miss from this talk what should I
have given so tell me at the end what's
missing and what was useful to you I
really would value that feedback right
now so you know who I am I wrote a book
we're doing this for a very long time
before I tell you what my observations
are on where the problems are in
delivering data science projects is
trying to warm you up with a previous
talk I need some feedback from you now
I'd like a couple of observations from
you on personal observations or just
observations you've seen around you why
is it that data science projects don't
necessarily get delivered successfully
and a bunch of you do this on a weekly
or monthly basis because you're using
all of the tools so you must have
experiences
okay absolutely some missing data that's
one of my points definitely what other
points are there one of the reasons are
there why things don't work too high
expectations yep definitely
oh yeah absolutely that's a good one
see I think magic make money you just
here's the thing make me famous
and yeah that's what do we do with it
any others can be one more one questions
Oh what do you mean by that
okay so these are my observations and I
think you're just nervous what you've
been saying
so that desire for magic here's some
data I'm the boss I want a Ferrari make
me a Ferrari but I don't know how I
don't know what I need I don't know what
given you would just want a Ferrari and
that desire for magical is infuriating
and the second one a vanity project so
my mates in other companies have data
science teams so I want a data science
team too so data scientists via the data
science thing and make me a Ferrari but
without any desire to actually see a
real thing coming through and no strong
need probably no data that lack of
technical leadership that's a problem I
encounter where I have to talk not just
to the data scientists who could be very
well trained but not trained in how to
deal with management and then I have to
turn to the manage bonus thing right
you've got special people here you can't
just say government do magic and expect
something to occur when you have no idea
what you need or what the data looks
like we need to think about what the
technical leadership looks like and what
it means to manage a project that isn't
just technical so it's not just being a
CTO and managing a software project with
some well-defined
outcomes and some known technologies but
also you've got unknown data and unknown
methodology in this we've got three
things that can confound and those
uncertainties can multiply together bad
data I've given talks on bad data
there's loads of bad data it mean theta
lies to you a lot of the time I assume
all data is lying unless I can prove
otherwise and that's the easiest place
the star from the data is out to get
but if the data is not out to get me
it's probably full of mistakes and
somebody tells me some very polite
interpretation as to what's in the
database
and it turns out it's full of rubbish
and someone just miss entered it and
it's got bad timestamps it's got badly
coded entries or you're missing chunks
of it and then it's all confused because
it changed over time and no one
documented those changes and you're
supposed to do magic for this and then
lack of bionis over the client so you're
told to deliver magic because the boss
wants the Ferrari but the person you're
delivering magic to doesn't need this
thing this thing just a pain in the
backside to them so they don't want it
anyway and you're left in between
there's lots of reasons why this goes
wrong there's a couple of huh lots of
good data science projects so numerous
management asking sensible questions was
brilliant you've got a manager you can
talk to and they don't mind talking
about the uncertainties and difficulties
and where the value is suitable dates
are so data that is complete enough good
enough doesn't lie too much so we can do
something with it and we've got well
defined outcomes that are agreed to be
achievable so we've got some stretch
goals that might will get us all a
Ferrari but we've got some useful goals
that might actually just see us
surviving our jobs are not getting fired
it's a great place to be so I've been
developing a bunch of the the lessons
that I'm talking more about now
companies like these so some of those
are corporates and so Channel four huge
broadcaster in daro might be a name out
here it's from from the UK we know it as
a nearshore Romanian outsourcing group
and so I don't know if it's endeavor
known out here is a thing yeah yeah okay
and QBE huge insurer and then some
smaller companies and back in the UK so
the different levels of dealing with
data science different environments
corporate startup and then seeing how
these things work in different ways over
many years so I'm going to run through a
couple of slides on some suggestions and
I'm hoping that all of you get at least
that one thing out of these slides just
once they can all be happy so a project
specification I think all projects
should start with some kind of
specification just a couple of pages
maybe could be a bit longer and at least
a few pages that tells us things like
what
problem is that we're solving so we all
agree couple of paragraphs this is
actually the problem we're solving not
there's crazy other problem in somebody
else's head where are the unknowns what
are the things that might damage the
project or kill it or slow it down or
confuse us so at least they're written
down and we can decide are they
dangerous do we want to do something
about them or we all agree that these
risks exist we can have a set of
milestones over the next couple of
months we're going to try and achieve
this this and this and if everything
goes well maybe this in this as well and
we can see what the expectations are
then so we can do expectation management
with the clients and people around us do
we have a gold standard data set so do
we have data that we trust that's well
annotated so if we're doing a supervised
classification problem who gave us the
labels to be trust the label does
somebody make the labels are they full
of lies really good and then what's the
definition of dump when we get to the
end you actually know what the end is
you know is it an a UC score of 65% or
is it something Carol 66% and 90% I mean
why what are these numbers mean so why
is a human interpretation of these
numbers and are they stated clearly I
like to say they have a data story this
was documented by a colleague of mine in
London and berto and he wrote an article
on medium about this - the data story
lets us explain that we understand our
data and a data story can be something
like a jupiter notebook you load in some
data and then you graph it and then you
explain what these graphs mean so this
is i've got 10 columns of data these a
lot of columns mean and these are the
main relationships between the columns
say between pairs or between triples of
columns so this is the dynamics that we
see in the dates at the time series of
longitude of the data whatever we've got
and it's probably a notebook and if it's
a notebook you can run it on a new data
set and then you can save it out and you
can use NBD converts to convert that
notebook into an HTML artifact you can
add it to your get repo because you're
all good developers and you do source
control and then you have a nice HTML
document that you can read and print out
and share and stick on the wall and
everyone can see this story in the story
has lots of human interpretation in it
but you'll have a really good ranks
about dirty data just crappy data in
general so if you if you don't think you
know enough about 30 days for yet
of story and if you want to read about
exploratory data analysis and
documenting the the data you've been
given
I really recommend Burt to us our
article just so what does bad data look
like there's a bunch of standardized
approaches that we can use from we
tackle our data science projects rather
than to people sitting in the room
solving the same problems differently
when they're all the panel problems are
really boring problems things like
cookie cutter for this Ehrman if you
serve cookie cutter data science there's
a cookie cutter recipes that cookie
cutter gives you a standard fold a
template for django projects and for
python projects and art projects
there's one for data science for python
it gives us a standard layout and a
bunch of standard ways of writing the
beginnings of our notebooks so that you
haven't got to think about where do I
store my data and how do I process my
data and how do I first visualize my
data as a standard for it's nice and
easy everyone has some criticism of it
because it's a standard of course they
do but it just takes away one set of
uncertainties you can get going a bit
quicker pandas profiling it's a
brilliant tool so pandas profiling is
the diagram on the bottom right every
time you get a data frame and he do got
described and got info you're describing
the data
numerically and then maybe you do some
graphs out of that pandas profiling has
some JavaScript which it's full of
graphs describing your data visually and
you can export that as an HTML file and
then you get an artifact to put into
your get will to mark and the top right
those are the likely is that you've got
installed another version numbers that
you're using in your project set up so
that in six months time when you come
back to your project you can see which
lie but she'll be using so you can
recreate it somewhere else just makes a
boring problem go away and but your
hands up if you're using anaconda the
anaconda environments probably lots of
you what one of you should be using it
anaconda takes away all those boring
problems with installing libraries and
then transferring the setup between
machines I strongly recommend you all
just switch to anaconda and take away
the boring problem of library management
because it dissolves a lot of problems
everyone needs to improve their code
quality and if you're if you're not
collaborating and having your code
review by the people then your code will
suffer as a result and there's a bunch
of things you should be doing around
that so I always strongly encourage
criticisms of code and techniques for
improving it some easy ways are using
assert statements inside your notebooks
to encode your assumptions so in six
months time when you come back and you
wonder if the age column really meant
ages of humans which means they must be
positive integers probably less than a
hundred and twenty or ages in days or
ages of something else if you have an
assert statement saying a certain age
less than 120 and greater than zero we
know what our range is and we don't
forget about us
whenever you get duplicated code you
want to refactor it so take the
duplicated blocks out probably put it
into a Python file and if you're doing
that then you've only got one place to
edit one bit of logic rather than
duplicated logic and if you've got one
place you can start testing it with unit
tests put your hands up if you write
unit tests some of you great the rest of
you write unit tests and they really
make your life easier when you come back
later on you make a bit of change in
your code you run your tests and
something else breaks and your unit
tests can point out some other
assumptions you made a while ago where
you've modified some other bit of code
and it's having knock-on effect rather
than being ignorant of that knock-on
effect it becomes very visible and so
you don't start shooting yourself in the
foot we can do visual reports so
diagrams two dimensional one dimensional
diagrams with an analyst interpretation
explaining what we're seeing in the data
so not just graphing it and then being
lazy because we know what that graph
means and we forget to explain it but
actually writing down the explanation so
a colleague can read it all in six
months time when we come back to it you
can go back to and go that's what I was
doing right because I've reminded myself
what it was that I was doing there and
it goes into your git repo of course and
so it's all there for all time
I never thought like yellow brick which
give you diagnostic and visual outputs
from your scikit-learn machine learning
there are lots of diagnostic official
tools out there I
strongly recommend you give them a go
and for coach quality who does code
reviews who's been involved in Co the
views again not enough of you and not
enough for most people it turns out code
reviews is where you sit down and a
colleague sits down and the colleague
looks at your code and criticizes you
and you know we don't like that we never
liked that but it turns out they
probably ask good questions and then we
sit down and code review their code and
we ask them good questions and then both
of our code qualities improve because we
fix the things that are obviously wrong
you can have to check list of that you
can follow the coding conventions like
pet aides there's n B dime to do diffing
on notebooks just like dipping modules
but instead the the notebook so that's
the diagram in the bottom rights
they're full of JSON output they're
quite hard to do a regular diff on NB
dime gives you that diffing and the
browsers are free really nice and then
this idea of a data defense so defending
your code to a colleague explaining I
did this modeling this way with this
kind of data and obviously the answer is
this and then your colleague asks you a
difficult question about your approach
or even just says but wasn't that data
out date yeah it probably was actually
and so it's a little bit like having
code view but it's a review upon your
methodology and it's very honest way to
start defending your code if you get
through some of those you can really
begin to trust actually my code is good
and my methodology is good if you never
do those things you have to ask yourself
how do I know that wyvern
actually works and he's solving the real
problem you need to be delivering to a
client it could be an academic client or
a commercial clients it doesn't have to
be a finished delivery of course but
some kind of continuous delivery so
early on just doing reporting and then
building up to whatever user interface
or he might ultimately be delivering so
rather than trying to do some kind of
huge bang final delivery and hooray we
hope it works but lots of little
deliveries I found that's a very same
way to iron out all the little problems
because as soon as you start the
livering clients begin to ask you
questions about well how did you deal
with that really weird thing that I
remember
now happened to the dates at five years
ago and I've never mentioned that thing
before but until you get to delivery no
one thinks about some of those weird
things about highlights a bunch of
uncertainties from the outside of your
project which is incredibly useful and
there's a project called paper mill from
Netflix where they're they're working to
productionize notebooks without any code
rework so you take your notebook and
then you deploy it because you've
written it with a couple of extra tools
so you can use in R&D and then you can
deploy it to a thousand machines and go
into a grid search on it or go and put
it out in a scaling cluster for
responding to client requirements so
paper mill looks like a really nice way
to bridge the deployment gap that we get
from working in notebooks upfront so
I'll summarize here and I always push
for strong honesty in the work that we
do so I don't mind saying you know I
write code I write code when I'm tired
that means my code quality can go down
and probably because I've written my
code I'm not going to notice that the
code quality has gone down I need a
colleague to sit down sayin that comic
makes no sense the variable names are
rubbish and that functions way too long
and you should refactor and clean it up
and put a unit test around it oh yeah
that was being lazy I really should go
and do those things so we need to be
honest than all of our work we need to
keep improving our technique I talked to
many clients where people are so fixated
on delivery they forget to go and get
better at their tooling but all of us
we're where artists we have to get
better with the tools we have around us
if you're not practicing and improving
you just get a bit stale then it's quite
hard to catch up so keep trying to
introduce new techniques all the time
and keep communicating your results
that's the biggest takeaway keep sharing
your results and sharing your methods
and that way you get interesting
questions coming back and that way
you've got a chance to fix any problems
and deliver a good final result and that
makes your clients happy
and I'll finish there thank you very
much
[Applause]
are there any questions there I totally
haven't told you very much at all there
there must be some questions you can
always ask me questions ever be a later
on no questions
well in that case then how do we go from
here I think there's there's stickers
everyone needs and we probably need to
get some beer
it's great for beer yeah okay well in
that case thank you very much all right
thank you very much everyone
[Applause]